hola ya tenía muchas ganas de regresar a
hacer estos vídeos estamos los vídeos
del st y bueno aunque tengo muchas ganas
me siento un poco enfermo de la gripa
así que espero no enfermarme o no
enfermarme muy fuerte para así poder
seguir trabajando en estos vídeos por
cierto ya estamos en el examen 5 en la
sección número 9 en la pagina 679 le
hemos avanzado bastante y vamos a
resolver el problema número uno así que
venga de una vez si de cada diez
automóviles de una cierta marca seis de
ellos son rojos a ver tomemos el color
rojo seis de ellos son rojos ok
cuál es la probabilidad de que un auto
seleccionado al azar de esta marca sea
rojo es decir seis de cada diez seis de
cada diez son rojos por lo tanto la
probabilidad de tomar uno de estos al
azar es 6 entre 10 lo cual
ok esto no está en nuestros sencillos
pero bien de tres quintos que es
exactamente lo mismo si yo me tomo 6
entre 10 esto es exactamente lo mismo
que si se acometa de arriba y saco mitad
abajo me quedaría 3 sobre 5 tengo tres
quintos de probabilidad de obtener un
automóvil rojo tres quintos de
probabilidad de obtener un automóvil
rojo que por cierto es el inciso b ya
está tengo aquí el problema número uno y
vamos a resolver el problema número dos
el problema número dos que tiene un
triángulo muy parecido a este así que
déjame hacerlo tengo un trémolo así
después va algo con por acá y después
tengo algo por acá después tengo una
línea que baja más o menos como por acá
ok y tengo las siguientes letras a y los
siguientes ángulos este es el punto a
ver y se me dicen qué
en el ángulo w este es el ángulo w este
de aquí es el ángulo z este vale x y
este balde
ok y este punto en donde intersecta está
pues parece ser una altura se llama de
ok y que me dicen la figura siguiente
está hecha escala si b es igual
abc si ave es igual a veces esto es muy
importante si ven esto es lo mismo que
esto de aquí entonces estamos hablando
de que es un triángulo isósceles y si es
un triángulo isósceles también podemos
concluir que este ángulo es lo mismo que
este ángulo ya lo hemos visto varias
veces estos dos ángulos deben de ser
iguales si estos dos lados son iguales y
además nos dicen y sipe de bd biseca el
lado hacen biseca hace eso esencialmente
lo que quiere decir es que esta línea
verde
parte a la mitad a la línea hace al
segmento de línea hace o dicho de otra
manera llega justo al punto medio o de
otra manera esta distancia y esta
distancia es la misma estas dos
distancias son las mismas y lo que nos
dicen es cuando los siguientes incisos
no se puede concluir con la siguiente
información ok vamos a poner los
sencillos para ver de qué estamos
hablando el primer inciso el inciso
ahmed es lo siguiente
wv es igual a equis el inciso b me dice
w es igual a z el inciso se me dice x es
igual a james
abc de enciso t me dice que hable es
igual a de c y por último tengo a veces
de m
me dice que ve de b/d
perpendicular a a
hace perfecto cuáles de estos los puedo
concluir con la información que tengo y
cuáles no puedo concluir con la
información que tengo de hecho lo que me
preguntan es cuando los siguientes
sencillos no se puede concluir con esta
información y bueno w es igualdad se
está estudiando concluimos desde hace
rato eso estaba muy fácil de concluir
por lo tanto este no es el que no se
puede concluir este fue que concluimos
hace rato entonces esta es la respuesta
correcta que dice a w
igual a x w es igual a x bueno
aquí no parecen ser iguales no sé si
forzosamente tengan que ser iguales creo
que está creo que esta es la respuesta
correcta a ver veamos las demás el
inciso se me dicen x es igual a 10 x es
igual ayer eso sí lo podemos concluir
porque vende biseca a hacer y sin vender
y seca al lado hace esto quiere decir
que este ángulo
i
de ángulo deben de ser iguales también
estaba secando a este ángulo completo y
por lo tanto si ves debbie seca a hacer
este si lo podemos construir y no es mi
respuesta correcta a d es igual a dc a
desigualdades en eso ya lo habíamos
sacado esto ya lo habíamos concluido y
por lo tanto no es mi respuesta correcta
verde es perpendicular a se ve de verde
es perpendicular a hacer eso también es
cierto este ángulo de 90 grados y este
agudo también es de 90 grados y eso lo
podemos concluir porque estos dos lados
deben de ser iguales es más deja de
dibujar por aquí otro triángulo
imagínate que yo tengo un triángulo que
este lado y este lado sean iguales ok y
además tengo una recta por aquí que me
seca al otro de los dos lados si me seca
a este lado y entonces aquí tengo el
triángulo antes de ponerlo con nuestro
color aquí tengo mi triángulo y este
ángulo yo sé que es lo mismo
este ángulo y estos los ángulos también
son iguales no queda de otra esta recta
debe de cortar justo en un ángulo de 90
grados por lo tanto esto sí lo podemos
concluir que venden sea perpendicular a
hacer esto tiene que ver mucho con los
ángulos y con que tenemos dos lados
iguales y que esta distancia esto mismo
que esta distancia justo este triángulo
que tenemos aquí por lo tanto esto sí se
puede concluir y no es mi respuesta
entonces creo que la respuesta correcta
es que w es igual a equis e inclusive
eso lo podemos pensar de la siguiente
manera fíjate bien si yo tengo aquí el
triángulo a como éste que tenga dos
lados iguales parecidos a estos ok y
después tengo otro por acá y después
tengo me altura vamos a ponerla con
color rojo
tengo una altura por acá ok en este caso
w de este ángulo y llévale este ángulo
ahora podemos tomarnos otro triángulo
con las mismas características que sea
más o menos así que se vea algo así este
lado sea igual a éste
y después tenga aquí mi otro lado y
después tengo mi altura de altura se ve
más o menos así y entonces en este caso
ya cambiaron los ángulos me estoy
fijando en este ángulo y en este ángulo
y parece ser que no son iguales al menos
no es lo mismo este caso que tengo un
ángulo más pequeño y un ángulo más
grande aquí a este caso en el cual se
parecen bastante los ángulos por lo
tanto no forzosamente puedo concluir que
w sea igual a equis y es justo lo que me
pedía el problema número dos por lo
tanto mi respuesta es el inciso a venga
volvemos las pantallas para ver qué nos
dice el problema número tres el problema
número tres y me dice si el 30% de m es
40 ok el 30% de m es lo mismo que 40 o
bueno recuerda que esto lo podemos ver
en su forma decimal como punto 30
dm de m-sport m punto 30 m
esto es lo mismo que 40 lo que me
preguntan es cuánto vale el 15% a cuánto
equivale el 15% de m y bueno
esencialmente lo que quiero que te des
cuenta aquí es que el 15% es la mitad
del 30% tú podrás resolver aquí la
ecuación para m
o tal vez decir bueno puedo hacer una
regla de tres es decir 30 por ciento es
40 y bueno pues el 15 por ciento cuánto
es
esto también lo podrías hacer todo
despejar de que amaine pero
esencialmente lo que quiero que te des
cuenta es que el 15% es la mitad del 30%
por lo tanto si me tomo la mitad del
punto 30 m que es 40 entonces la mitad
de 40 va a ser 20 el 15% de m es 20 15%
de m va a ser 20 y bueno ha dicho otra
forma de resolverlo es dividir entre 2
a parte de la ecuación y dividir entre 2
esta parte de la ecuación y llegaríamos
a lo mismo pero la clave de esto es
darse cuenta que el 15% es la mitad del
30%
ok problema número 4 problema número 4
es dice si n es cualquier número
negativo n es cualquier número negativo
en es menor que cero ok
cuál de los incisos corresponde a un
número positivo y tengo inciso am en
entre 2 inciso b 3 n inciso c en + 3
inciso d n menos 3 y por aquí el inciso
m que es 2 - el ok lo que quiero que te
des cuenta es que un número negativo
para hacer lo positivo lo que
necesitamos es o elevarlo al cuadrado o
multiplicarlo por un número negativo o
en su dado caso sumarle un número mucho
más grande que el un número positivo por
lo tanto en este primer caso podemos
decir que en entre 2 también va a ser
negativo
un número negativo entre 2 es negativo
lo que queremos es un número positivo
por lo tanto esta no es mi respuesta
correcta si lo multiplicó por un número
positivo me va a dar un número negativo
lo cual no es mi respuesta correcta aquí
en este caso es interesante n + 3 en 3
podría ser un número positivo eso es muy
cierto pero si n es cualquier número
negativo podría valer por ejemplo menos
10 y menos 10 más 3 no le alcanza para
ser positivo me daría menos 7 en el caso
de que en el fuera entero si fuera 1 y 2
pues esto sería cierto pero 100 es un
número más pequeño o igual que menos 3
pues esto no sería cierto por lo tanto
ésta tampoco es una respuesta correcta a
un número negativo si tú le sumas un
número negativo o en dado caso de restas
un número positivo se va a ser más
negativo si tú debes algo y después
debes más vas a deber mucho más por lo
tanto ésta tampoco es mi respuesta y
existe una respuesta y aquí está mi
respuesta porque darte cuenta de lo
siguiente si el navaleno
valga menos 10 cuando yo era multiplique
por menos menos por menos me va a dar
más
esto me quedaría dos menos menos 10 lo
cual es lo mismo que dos más 10 menos
por menos me la da más y después 2 más
10 es lo mismo que 12 y es un número
positivo cualquier número negativo si tú
lo multiplicas por menos por el signo
negativo entonces me va a dar un número
positivo y un número positivo +2 siempre
va a ser un número positivo por lo tanto
mi respuesta es el inciso
justo lo que yo quería ok resolvamos
aquí el número 5 creo que todavía me da
espacio para resolverlo veamos que me
dice la razón de 1.2 a 1
de 1.2 a 1 esta razón que por cierto
esto mismo lo podemos escribir como 1.2
sobre 1 es lo mismo la razón de 1.2 a
uno es equivalente a cuál de las
siguientes razones ok
veamos el inciso am me dice 1 a 2 1 a 2
eso no es cierto porque en este caso uno
es más pequeño que 2 y aquí tengo que
1.2 es más grande que uno esto no
quedaría igual a 1 entre 2 y esto no
tiene nada de lógica porque este número
es más grande que uno y éste es más
pequeño que uno por lo tanto eso no es
cierto entonces este inciso no es cierto
vamos a ver el inciso b el inciso b me
dice 12 a 1 de igual manera 12 a unos
números muy grande aquí tengo 1.2 a 11.2
entre 1 no es lo mismo que 12 entre 1
por lo tanto el inciso b tampoco es
cierto el inciso b tampoco es cierto el
inciso c
5 a 6 5 a 6 y también lo podemos
eliminar de una manera muy rápida porque
5 es un número más pequeño que 6 este
tampoco es cierto que el exceso de me
dice 6 a 5 y creo que esta es la
respuesta correcta esto será lo mismo
que 6 sobre 5
pues parece que sí y 10 más vamos a
verificarlo si yo me tomo el 6 y lo
divido entre 5 digo cabe una vez uno por
cinco es 5 aquí lo resto y me sobra 1
pongo un punto decimal y bajó un 0 estás
de acuerdo y ahora sí 5 cabe dos veces
en diez dos veces en diez por lo tanto 6
en 35 es lo mismo que 1.2 que es lo
mismo que 1.2 a 1 por lo tanto mi
respuesta correcta es el inciso de muy
bien me da tiempo de hacer una más
siguiente problema volvemos de pesaron y
vamos a hacer el problema número 6 la
explicación de una imagen dice que esta
figura equivale a 5 millones de nuevas
casas
tengo una figura más o menos así
esto sería una casa y esta esta figura
equivale a 5 millones de casas millones
de casas nuevas ok y después me dice
aproximadamente a cuántas nuevas casas
equivalen los siguientes símbolos y me
ponen 3 casas
una por la caja y otra por acá algo así
y otra por acá tres casas y media y
después tengo media casa algo más o
menos y lo que me van a preguntar es
precisamente a cuántos millones de casas
nuevas equivalen esta expresión que
tengo aquí ok bueno rapidísimo podemos
ver que de estas tres tengo tres por
cada una de éstas valen cinco millones
por cinco millones y esto me va a dar 15
millones 15 millones y bueno esto de
estas tres pero aquí tengo media casa
más y ojo el problema o donde te podés
equivocar es si piensas que aquí tengo
medio millón solamente y no lo que tengo
es la mitad de cinco millones de casas
más por lo tanto a 15 millones de tengo
que sumar a 2.5 que es la mitad de 5
millones 2.5 millones de casas nuevas
más y bueno cuando es esto esto es lo
mismo que 17 puntos 5 millones de casas
y esa es mi respuesta que es el inciso d
de hecho hay otra forma de resolverlo tú
podrías multiplicar 3.5 3.5 por 5
millones y así obtener el resultado pero
bueno lo más importante es que no te
equivoques pensando que esta es la mitad
de una casa o tal vez medio millón de
casas sino que más bien es la mitad de 5
millones de casas qué es lo que equivale
una de estas figuras como la que tengo
aquí y bueno pues mi respuesta es el
inciso dem y con esto nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo